>> Sean: THANK GOD FOR SMALL
FAVORS.
TUCKER, THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY" THIS MONDAY
NIGHT.
ANOTHER SHOCKING NEWS SCANDAL AS
WE COME ON THE AIR THIS HOUR,
9:00 ON THE EAST COAST,
6:00 P.M. OUT WEST.
ANDREW CUOMO, ONE EXECUTIVE JUST
FILED A BRAND-NEW ETHICS
COMPLAINT RAISING IS CONCERNED
OF THE GOVERNOR AND PEOPLE
AROUND HIM WERE USING A LOYALTY
TEST TO DETERMINE WHETHER
COUNTIES WOULD GET SUPPLIED WITH
THE COVID-19 VACCINE.
AS YOU CAN SEE THE WALLS ARE
CLOSING IN TIGER BY THE HOUR FOR
THE NEW YORK GOVERNOR.
WE HAVE A LOT MORE COMING UP,
ALL THE LATEST DETAILS.
ALSO, SHOCKING,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" JUST
ISSUED A MAJOR RETRACTION FROM A
FIXED NEWS STORY SURROUNDING
PRESIDENT TRUMP BUT THEY HAVE
YET TO APOLOGIZE FOR THE THREE
YEARS OF TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION
LIES OR THEIR HORRIFIC EARLY
COVERAGE OF CORONAVIRUS.
JOE BIDEN AS PRESIDENT.
OH, WE ARE NOT TO BELIEVE
JOURNALISTIC INTEGRITY HAS ALL
OF A SUDDEN RETURNED TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
WE HAVE THAT STORY FOR YOU
TONIGHT AND LATER, SARA CARTER
WILL JOIN US FROM A FAMILY FARM
THAT WAS NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THE
DEMOCRATS ’US TO TRILLION DOLLAR
COVID-19 EMERGENCY STIMULUS AND
THEY SAY BECAUSE THEY DID NOT
MEET THE BILL’S "RACIAL
REQUIREMENTS" BUT FIRST,
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN IN OFFICE FOR
54 DAYS.
HE HAS YET TO HOLD A SINGLE
OFFICIAL PRESS CONFERENCE.
THAT IS NOW OFFICIALLY THE
LONGEST A SITTING U.S. PRESIDENT
HAS GONE WITHOUT A PRESS
CONFERENCE IN OVER 100 YEARS.
THE SO-CALLED "BIDEN BLITZ" THAT
THE MEDIA MOB HAS BEEN HYPING
APPARENTLY CONSISTS OF THIS.
ONE EXTREMELY SHORT, SCRIPTED
PUBLIC EVENT PER DAY.
ONE A DAY, WHICH IS SEEMINGLY
ABOUT AS MUCH AS JOE CAN HANDLE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, WITH OR WITHOUT
JOE BIDEN, HIS PARTY’S RADICAL,
EXTREME SOCIAL AGENDA, THAT’S
MOVING FULL STREAM AHEAD.
AND THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS
IS YES, REDISTRIBUTION AND
WEALTH CONFISCATION.
IN FACT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
WE CAN NOW TELL YOU IS PLANNING
WHAT WILL BE THE SINGLE BIGGEST
TAX HIKE ON AMERICANS IN OVER
THREE DECADES.
THIS RADICAL GREEN NEW DEAL OF
SOCIALISM HAS TO BE PAID FOR BY
SOMEBODY AND, BY THE WAY, THEY
HAVE A NEW WEALTH TAX ON EVERY
THING ELSE, JANET YELLEN HAS
CALLED FOR, ELIZABETH WARREN’S
TAX.
HOLD ONTO YOUR WALLETS, BUCKLE
UP FOR ALL THE CLASS WARFARE AND
ALL THAT RHETORIC.
WE ARE TAKING IT FROM THOSE EVIL
RICH PEOPLE, THOSE EVIL
CORPORATIONS AND THOSE EVIL
OTHER PEOPLE.
THE RADICAL SOCIALISM INCLUDES
RAISING CORPORATE TAX RATES FROM
21 TO 28%, RAISING THE INCOME
TAX RATE SUPPOSEDLY ONLY ON HIGH
EARNERS.
HOW DO WE DEFINE IT?
RAISING THE CAPITAL GAINS TAX
RATE AND RAISING TAX RATES ON
SMALL BUSINESSES AND OF COURSE
THEY ALSO WANT TO EXPAND THE
DEATH TAX.
IN OTHER WORDS THEY WANT TO
RAISE TAXES ON MONEY THAT YOU
MAKE, MONEY THAT YOU INVEST AND
PUT AT RISK, IF YOU MAKE MORE
MONEY, THEY WANT A PIECE OF THAT
ACTION.
THE MONEY YOU STILL HAVE LEFT
WHEN YOU FINALLY DIE AND IN THE
INTERIM THEY ARE GOING TO GO
BACK AND GET ANOTHER BITE AT THE
APPLE WITH THE WEALTH TAX AND
THEN TO TOP IT ALL OFF,
EVERYTHING THAT YOU BUY WILL BE
COSTING YOU MORE MONEY BECAUSE
THE CORPORATE INCOME TAX RATE --
YEAH, THAT’S GOING TO BE PASSED
ON TO ALL OF US, YOU I’M OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE CONSUMER.
THE REGULATIONS ON INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS, THAT COULD ACTUALLY
PUT MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS OUT OF WORK BY NOW
MAKING IT NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
HIRE PEOPLE FOR THEIR SERVICES
IF THEY OWN THEIR OWN BUSINESS,
LIKE TO WORK FOR DIFFERENT
COMPANIES, THAT’S PAYBACK
BASICALLY FOR THE UNIONS AND ALL
THEIR ELECTION SUPPORT.
COUPLE ALL OF THIS WITH THE
RAPIDLY RISING GAS PRICES, HOW
MUCH IT COSTS TO FILL YOUR TANK.
RISING HEATING AND COOLING
COSTS, GET READY.
THAT’S ALL BEING CAUSED BY THE
BITE IN THE ADMINISTRATION
GETTING AWAY FROM -- WELL, WE’VE
BEEN ENERGY INDEPENDENT FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN SANDY FIVE YEARS.
IT’S THEIR ANTI-FRACKING,
ANTI-PIPELINE VIRTUE SIGNALING
AND YOU NOW HAVE A RECIPE FOR
WHAT WILL BE ECONOMIC DISASTER
FOR EVERY HARDWORKING AMERICAN
IN THE U.S.
YOU WILL ALL BE IMPACTED, YOU
WILL ALL BE PAYING MORE AND
SAVING THE WORLD FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE AND OF COURSE CLIMATE
CHANGE DESTRUCTION IN 12 YEARS
AND TURNING AMERICA INTO A
SOCIALIST HELLHOLE.
OF COURSE THAT’S NOT CHEAP.
THIS ONLY RAISES AN ESTIMATED
$2 TRILLION OUT OF THE
$90 TRILLION THAT WILL BE NEEDED
FOR THE NEW GREEN DEAL
SOCIALISM.
BUCKLE UP, MORE TAX HIKES ARE
HEADED YOUR WAY.
NOBODY WILL BE SPARED,
GUARANTEED.
KEEP IN MIND, AMERICANS IN RED
STATES, THEY’VE ALREADY COUGHED
UP BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN WHAT
MIGHT BE THE BIGGEST BLUE STATE
BAILOUT IN THE HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY.
IF YOU LIVE IN A STATE WHERE YOU
ELECT RESPONSIBLE LEGISLATURES,
GOVERNORS, GUESS WHAT?
CONGRATULATIONS, BECAUSE YOUR
HARD-EARNED MONEY IS ABOUT TO GO
TO GOVERNORS IN BLUE STATES AND
STATE LEGISLATURES IN BLUE
STATES WHERE THEY TAX AND SPEND
BEYOND THEIR MEANS, WHERE THEY
NEVER BALANCE THEIR BUDGET, THEY
DON’T EVER FUND THEIR PENSIONS
AND WHERE GOVERNMENT CORRUPTION
RUNS RAMPANT.
ILLINOIS GETTING A MASSIVE
$13 BILLION OF YOUR MONEY.
NEW YORK STATE GETTING A
WHOPPING 24 BILLION.
CALIFORNIA, THEY GET THE GOLD
PRIZE.
THEY’VE GOT A WHOPPING
$42 BILLION FROM YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
ACCORDING TO FoxNews.com AND
THEIR REPORT, CERTAIN COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA ARE CONSIDERING
USING THAT MONEY AS BONUSES FOR
TEACHERS, INCLUDING THOSE WHO
HAVE NOT SET FOOT IN A CLASSROOM
FOR MONTHS.
ONE TEACHER’S UNION EVEN
SUGGESTED THAT IF THEY GET THE
BONUS, IT MIGHT BE FUN TO TAKE A
TRIP TO HAWAII.
LET THAT SINK IN.
YOU’RE A TEACHER IN TEXAS,
YOU’RE A TEACHER IN FLORIDA,
MISSISSIPPI, ANY OTHER RED STATE
WHERE SCHOOL HAS BEEN AND IS IN
SESSION, JUST KNOW THAT YOUR
HARD-EARNED TAX DOLLARS MIGHT
SOON BECOME A VACATION FUND FOR
TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY’S RADICAL
DECISIONS ARE GOING TO HAVE VERY
IMMEDIATE, REAL CONSEQUENCES.
THIS ISN’T ABOUT TAXES AND
SPENDING.
LOOK AT WHAT’S HAPPENING FOR
EXAMPLE AT THE BORDER.
AFTER HALTING BORDER WALL
CONSTRUCTION, BOWING TO INCREASE
IMMIGRATIONS AND PROMISING
AMNESTY TO MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS, CONVENIENTLY IN THREE
YEARS, JUST IN TIME TO VOTE,
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE NOW POURING INTO
THE U.S. ACROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY.
IT IS NOW SO BAD THAT MEXICO’S
PRESIDENT IS REFERRING TO BIDEN
AS THE MIGRANTS PRESIDENT.
AROUND 100,000 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WERE DETAINED AT THE
U.S.-MEXICO BORDER JUST FOR THE
MONTH OF FEBRUARY ALONE.
BY THE WAY, REMEMBER THE CAGES
FOR KIDS?
THEY WERE BUILT BY BIDEN AND
OBAMA AND IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION GOT BLAMED BY THE
MEDIA MOB THAT LIE ALL THE TIME.
WELL, THEY ARE BACK AND THEY ARE
WORSE THAN EVER.
MANY OF THESE CHILD MIGRANTS OR
FACILITIES ARE NOTHING MORE THAN
A FEW TENTHS OR SHIPPING
CONTAINERS, CARGO SHIPPING
CONTAINERS, YOU KNOW, THE ONES
WITH A TINY WINDOW WITH BARS ON
THEM.
ACCORDING TO CBS NEWS, ONE OF
THOSE FACILITIES IS NOW
OPERATING AT A WHOPPING 729%
CAPACITY.
SO MUCH FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING.
"SOME OF THE BOYS SAID THAT THE
CONDITIONS WERE SO OVERCROWDED
THEY HAD TO TAKE TURNS JUST TO
SLEEP ON THE FLOOR" AND "MOST OF
THE MINERS SAID THEY’D ONLY
SHOWERED ONCE WHILE EVEN IN THE
U.S."
THEY THOUGHT THEY WOULD BE HELD
FOR MORE THAN FIVE DAYS.
BY THE WAY, ALL TOLD, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS INCREASED THE
DETENTION OF MINORS IN THESE
CAGES BY 60% BUT ACCORDING TO
CIRCLE BACK WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY JEN PSAKI THIS IS
STILL NOT A CRISIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
SPEAKER DOES FEMA’S ARRIVAL AT
THE BORDER MEAN THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION FEELS WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER IS A
DISASTER?
>> I KNOW THAT WE ALWAYS GET
INTO THE FUN OF LABELS AROUND
HERE BUT I WOULD SAY OUR FOCUS
IS ON SOLUTIONS AND THIS IS ONE
OF THE STEPS THAT THE PRESIDENT
FELT WOULD HELP IT NOT BECOME A
FINAL SOLUTION BUT HELP EXPEDITE
PROCESSING, ENSURING PEOPLE WHO
COME ACROSS THE BORDER HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH AND MEDICAL
CARE.
CLEARLY THE NUMBERS ARE
ENORMOUS.
THIS IS A BIG CHALLENGE AND IT
CERTAINLY IS A REFLECTION OF
USING EVERY LOVER OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO HELP ADDRESS THAT.
>> Sean: HEALTH, MEDICAL CARE,
HOUSING.
ANYTHING WE ARE NOT GOING TO PAY
FOR?
YEAH, IT’S A PROBLEM CAUSED BY
BIDEN’S POLICIES.
NOW, WE ARE NOT HAVING FUN WITH
LABELS.
IT IS A FULL-BLOWN CRISIS OF
THEIR MAKING AND OF COURSE TOP
DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE ALWAYS
LOOKING TO BLAME SOMEBODY ELSE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE RECOGNIZE THIS IS A BIG
PROBLEM.
THE LAST OF ADMINISTRATION LEFT
US A DISMANTLED AND UNWORKABLE
SYSTEM AND LIKE ANY OTHER
PROBLEM, WE ARE GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SOLVE IT.
>> THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN
CHALLENGE TO ALL OF US.
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
INHERITED IS A BROKEN SYSTEM AT
THE BORDER AND THEY ARE WORKING
TO CORRECT THAT.
>> LET ME JUST SAY THIS,
JOE BIDEN INHERITED A HUGE MESS
ON IMMIGRATION AND IT’S NOT
GOING TO BE CLEANED UP IN A
MONTH.
HE’S ONLY BEEN IN OFFICE, YOU
KNOW, SINCE JANUARY 20TH.
ABOUT SIX WEEKS I GUESS IT IS.
>> Sean: NO, CHUCKIE, JOE
CAUSED THE CRISIS AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT IS A HEALTH CRISIS -- YES, IT
IS A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS OF HIS
MAKING.
IT’S ALSO A NATIONAL SECURITY
CRISIS ON TOP OF ALL OF THAT,